there are target honest that teaching
has become a less appealing field for a
lot of people that's I think an
overwhelmingly important problem
particularly when we're concerned about
equity because most districts are set up
have hirings personnel systems in which
the better teachers are able to get
themselves into the schools were there
in some sense least needed so that's I
think one of the most serious problems
the second is a failure to deal with
things outside of school that inhibit
achievement some of that is preschool
some of it is not some of it is harder
for policymakers to deal with but when
we have media and peer culture that that
are not supported of academic
achievement we're going to get less than
we otherwise would Margaret Mead many
many years ago said that children don't
need to respond to what their culture
rewards they just need to find out what
it is and if if we don't make academic
achievement something that is really
esteemed then we're just going to get a
lot less of it there has been some
movement in that regard I think there
are prints it's TV shows that glorify
smart people there are many there but
there are a few but in a lot of places
in the United States it's still more
important for a kid kids self-esteem to
do well in a sport than to do well in
school and certainly more important than
to do well in mathematics for example so
as long as we maintain those attitudes
we're going to get kids who say it
really isn't important to learn the
skills the policymakers are correctly
saying are important for our national
well-being
you